hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 58 hört zu und
spricht nach
ich heiße christian
meine freundin heißt paula
meine freundin heißt paula ich treffe
meine freundin
ich treffe meine freundin
ich spreche
meine freundin
mein fall
er heißt hans peter
mein vater heißt hans peter
ich rufe meinen vater an
ich telefoniere mit meinem vater
ich telefoniere mit meinem vater das ist
mein neues haus
das ist mein neues haus
ich ziehe in mein neues haus ein
ich ziehe im
ein neues haus ein
ich wohne in meinem neuen haus
ich wohne
einem neuen haus
das sind meine kinder
kennst du meine kinder
kennst du meine kinder ich spiele mit
meinen kindern
ich spiele mit meinen kindern
[Musik]
das ist christian
seine freundin heißt paula
er trifft seine freundin
er spricht mit seiner freundin
sein
er heißt hans peter
sein vater
heißt hans peter er ruft seinen
er ruft seinen
er telefoniert mit seinem vater
er
mit seinem vater das ist sein neues haus
das ist sein neues haus
ihr zieht in sein neues haus ein
er zieht in sein neues haus ein
wer wo
neuenhaus
er wohnt
einem neuen haus
das sind seine kinder das sind seine
kinder
kennst du seine kinder
er spielt mit seinen kindern
[Musik]
das ist paula
ihr freund heißt christian
ihr freund
heißt christian
sie trifft ihren freund
sie trifft ihren freund sie spricht mit
ihrem freund
sie spricht mit ihrem freund ihre mutter
heißt tina
ihre mutter
heißt china sie ruft ihre mutter an
sie ruft ihre mutter an
sie telefoniert mit ihrer mutter
das ist ihr neues haus
das ist ihr neues haus sie zieht in ihr
neues haus ein
sie zieht
neues haus ein sie wohnt in ihrem neuen
haus
sie wohnt in ihrem neuen haus
das sind ihre kinder
kennst du ihre kinder
sie spielt mit ihren kindern
[Musik]
daniel das ist eine super party
danke dass sie mich eingeladen hast
danke dass du gekommen bist leider ja
die party läuft gut mein bruder ist ein
guter dj das ist ein bruder ja die musik
ist super
wo sind eigentlich die anderen leute aus
unserer klasse ja also lisa konnte nicht
kommen ihr mann hatte einen unfall beim
sport jetzt ist sie bei ihrem mann im
spital
aber ich glaube es ist nicht so schlimm
er hat sich zwar seinen arm gebrochen
aber es ein arzt hat gesagt dass alles
gut kommt ach so ja und nach konnte
nicht kommen weil er mit seiner familie
diese woche in thailand in den ferien
ist tina ist jetzt leider auch nicht
hier weil ihr zug aus danzig verspätung
hatte und sie deshalb ihren flug in
warschau verpasst hat nein das ist aber
dumm gelaufen
und was ist mit marco marco musste heute
länger arbeiten sein chef ist in den
ferien und er muss jetzt die arbeit von
seinem geschäft machen
wow das ist aber gut für marco er
arbeite doch erst seit wenigen monaten
in dieser firma
marko hat gesagt dass es sehr gut für
seine karriere ist aber er hat auch
gesagt dass seine freundin nicht so
glücklich ist weil er so viel arbeit
na ja das glaube ich naja lasst uns
jetzt tanzen
[Musik]